[Music]
coming at you live from the roof of the
Spreckels theater in downtown San Diego
it's live at Conan Cod featuring
comedians Joel Kim booster Flula Borg
and marina Franklin and now you're live
at Conan Con host Moses store hello and
welcome to live at Kona Con I'm former
child bodybuilder and current heatstroke
victim
Moses storm if you're not already make
sure you're following live at Kona Con
to stay updated on all things that Conan
is doing down here at comic-con right
now I'm hosting the live pre-show we're
just moments away from the Conan show so
I have my correspondence that have been
out in the field all day grabbing all
that juicy comic-con content marina
Franklin say hello to her Joel Kim
booster and of course Flula Borg good
day to you how have you guys been so
great yeah it's showing your first
comic-con great yeah I love doing this
like just it feels like the Sun is we're
staring into the Sun oh yeah it's very
nice for people viewing at home you're
on Facebook or YouTube that's what we're
live-streaming all this stuff but make
sure you're sending us all your comments
will answer those throughout the show
we're live on Facebook and YouTube so
send us those comments we are looking at
those and and yeah we'll answer those
and we're gonna be checking in with
these guys in a little bit taking a look
at some of the videos and some of the
photos that they grab because you guys
were everywhere today every single thing
that we could possibly do before the
actual convention begins oh just
exclusive interviews with security
guards yes just blue-collar workers that
just want to be left alone hmm
we were out there bothering them exactly
made a lot of enemies today made a lot
out of it you're not allowed in most no
no in fact yeah really put a stop to a
lot of my comic-con activities for the
rest of the
we're gonna do a show inside but Joe
legally cannot be in the building now in
the live comment section one of the top
comments is where is Conan if you open
up any common chat as where is Conan I
can actually answer that right now very
special guests joining the show please
welcome Conan O'Brien live opponent I
will have you scoot down right on top of
everyone to succulents listen I've been
watching and you guys have established
an energy up here on this roof in this
sunlight that's deadly I'll tell you
that right now absolutely deadly toxic
an injury that borderlines aren't
complaining yes but but No
thank you so much all of you being here
and for being out there fluid you have
something you want to say no I'm excited
and you are speaking I did not want to
interrupt okay just settle down Flula
okay Flula have you had sugar in the
last hour
no it's been 122 minutes okay very good
just keep keep off the sugar for a while
copy that I have one complaint I was
trying to do a rehearsal not long ago
and then I'm seeing online that the Joel
snuck into our rehearsal that is a
sacred space no listen Rhea do you
understand what you understand I stayed
away that is a sacred space I am a I'm
like a priest well that's that's creepy
no I'm like a religious figure just
preparing his thoughts before a show and
you come bursting in with your
shenanigans I was asked to get BTS
behind the scenes forum you know shoot
listen if you're gonna do your poop
humor huh I'm gonna leave in 40 minutes
okay because I enjoy it you understand
where you are you got to understand the
room in the room I have to say very
excited about what's happening the team
cocoa house checked that out have you
seen it yet the team cocoa house
why yes I danced in front of it it was
wonderful are you gonna go by there I'm
gonna perform it I know that but when
are you performing tonight at 11:00 here
I want to come by tonight I wanna I want
to drop by strategically at certain
times I also want to sleep and eat there
yes incredibly I went today there's a
phone booth where people can leave you
voice messages yes then we got one from
my wife oh it says do not come home
that's the sound I found another three
formal ways that she speaks which one
did she find we don't want to talk about
it okay she's dating someone else it's
important Jimmy Fallon I came to say
we're streaming live as a pre-show today
yes and this was supposed to be an after
show but this is gonna sound like I'm
making this up but the reason we're
doing a pre-show is because there is a
real threat of not only a storm but
lightning yes and also let's point out
that we've constructed an aluminum cube
yes three-dimensional aluminum cube this
is a deathtrap I think Bruce Springsteen
would call it a suicide
absolutely this is a terrible place levy
thousand times I would die for Conan
I really would you like that conan guy
do ya and what have you seen today
marina that were excited you at
comic-con well I saw some black people I
cuz I I'm a nerd but I was good to see
there are other black nerds out there
yes that makes you feel good about the
african-american community that they're
that nerds nerds are out there in force
yeah I'm not alone no and you've been a
nerd your whole life I have been a nerd
that's what they've told me my whole
life
yeah now I'm coming out here it's
wonderful it's very nice yeah and Joel
what have you seen today well because of
the rain I tried to give some people
waiting in line to see the Breaking Bad
cast enter - you're taping today I tried
to give them some Poncho's and they tore
themselves apart we did he throw it have
them like it was a little more violent
with the way I threw the punches at the
crowd so it's not raining yet no and
it's about 95 degrees so who wants to
punch him now well I think it really is
anybody in this general vicinity in San
Diego just wants free I want free stuff
anything free yes my arm asking for a
pop figure ya know that people get crazy
about the pop figures now Flula yes
let's talk about you you've walked out
there have you have you greeted at
comic-con fans I've said hello to many
people there's lots of perspiration lots
of I've noticed some scoliosis I have
tried to massage some people's okay you
can't do that even if someone is like
had my back is sore please give me a
massage well if they ask for a massage
you're allowed to give them a massage
I've done you can't just diagnose people
with scoliosis Flula in this country I
know that in Germany this is popular but
you can't just diagnose someone with
scoliosis and then apply pressure to
their low back that's not cool it's an
s-shaped no weave okay it's a shape no
way Germany there's just roaming
chiropractors there's not legally
allowed to have an office there's an app
for that
yes food you mind standing for a moment
I want everyone to see what you're
wearing
Mirena maybe you could tell me what do
you think is that a good look for Flula
turn this way Flula it's a good look
yeah it matches his personality yes it
goes the fanny pack oh the I go to that
area in a disturbing way very disturbing
but look at organisation the Zippy x'
and the padding for emergency if
something comes trauma is produced
trauma protecting I see Lulu's got to
work with what he's got if no let's be
honest people's eyes would go to that
area and fanny pack er no if anything
it's it's being chased he's saying
protecting the area be modest yeah thank
very nice you know I sense it's clouding
over as we speak yeah as if the gods
were unhappy absolutely our
conversations our structure that we've
created taunting the gods saying do your
worst I you know I defy you yeah and
your lightning I mean that's what a
stupid thing for anyone to say what I
mean I'm not even a superstition but
here we are in an aluminum cube asking
for sky fire to rain down shaking my
fist at the sky which no one's done in
800 years you are the tallest person I
think you'd get struck first yes I'm a
tallest person one of
our people in Intellivision little known
fact and i add a vertebrae every year
you add one I add one you can surgically
add a vertebrae selective surgery they
just slip a disc in yeah yeah you could
be a superhero because there's no short
superheroes out there I've looked
ant-man famously sorry sorry I deflate
you immediately
Wolverine not many people know this he's
four seven four seven I guess I just
lost my geek thing yeah yeah you're I
think you're secretly really cool and
you're just trying to get in on this
nerd yeah I mean you're just pretending
yeah you were the coolest person in high
school I bet what does the inside of the
locker smell like all exactly no like
tennis balls no no no no erasers and
like salty tears yeah that's the answer
and sadness helicopter paparazzi is
closing and you can't see this on your
cameras and you can't even hear it but
just trust us helicopter paparazzi okay
make sure desperate to find out who
owned ins dating this week
Conan don't you mean the choppa ROTC no
you know Flula
if you're gonna do that kind of stuff
yes we can find you another country to
be in one man yes I would love this no
more of you no no no more of your puns
and your wordplay how do you say that in
German what should be trite certain
that's what vaudeville actor schleiden
man rekt beam - floor is closed what
watch peel that leap back that's Titan
yeah very punching me in the side of the
head with that aggressive wasn't true
that you're accidentally speaking
correct German words one julep claims
that one every six words I say in fake
German is a real German word your
percentage is increasing Conan I want
you to know litsen flower back time she
bashed Achtung lynnster out frigging
house litsen Frau Kate Weber own leaked
of tea I forgot but it sounds like you
said oh it Lady slippers sleds down the
icy rooftop yeah look at that
technically a sentence very well in
ladies slippers often do slide down the
roof I saw the monologue rehearsal
that's that's
you're opening the show that's my big
opener really daring this furniture cost
nothing
it looks worn in it looks very worn in
this is a man coming for a roof I know
last year we had at least some shade
this is from the skittles Museum I like
I just think it's nice to be outside
who's Kelly Ripa's co-host now is it
Ryan Ryan Ryan yeah the minute Regis was
gone I was out Michael Strahan the man
of football no no no Michael string is
gone yeah this is a big story this has
the feel of like when those two go to
San Diego and they're on a rooftop oh
you know audience it has that kind of
energy you don't know what's working
what's long-winded there's no live
audience you know what there's a very
forgiving audience out there on the web
right I know one thing about the
internet they're they're patient kind
they're kind they are they give
everything a chance and they see both
sides of the story always things that
you have no control of exactly just the
choices you made but we're honored to be
live streaming in one of your many open
tabs right now thank you for watching us
I don't know what else you were watching
what do you think I think we're just
like poor scrolling on Windows watching
yeah we're getting a lot of people that
were injured at work people that are
gearing up to sue people in Waiting
women wait audience I started at 12:30
at night my audience has always been
people in an emergency room waiting to
be treated a lot of pain yes and that
has always been my audience and now with
the internet and people watching yes you
know this now they're probably in an
emergency room and so again I have stuck
to my audience I've kept them throughout
all these ear and ear bass when I
perform live I do it in emergency rooms
yeah yes that's a true fact I believe
this you believe it yes wheelchairs and
what are the things a man uses to watch
yeah what are they called crotch man you
don't know the word crutch I fought it I
didn't you you don't think you
a lot of English but then you have weird
you don't know very simple words like
bowl or cup yes you say things like oh
it was a good cinema experience and I
really like seeing the llama but then he
drank out of the drinkie thing yes no
logic I have have you seen the
Switzerland cheese that is my vocabulary
brain okay a lot of holes in it yes I've
been working on different accents for a
Flula it's so good yes yes we've done a
lot which one are you working on did you
make yes Hey rude boy good boy phrase I
don't know does a Jamaican guy say thank
you you don't want to get caught up from
your show you're bombing today we have a
lot of fun comedy planned and then we
are going to reunite the Breaking Bad
cast for the 10th anniversary of the
premiere of one of the great or maybe
the greatest TV show of all time I'm
sure they'll be no debate about that on
the Internet Bryan Cranston Aaron Paul
and a gun Dean Norris Betsy Brandt RJ
Mitte Bob Odenkirk Vince Gillian and
Giancarlo Esposito Bob Odenkirk and I
started out as a we did a comedy team
bit on stage in Chicago in 1988 well got
started what was the what what what was
it what did you do together we translate
yeah yeah I know it wouldn't you need
but you'd need Bob here but need to
reenact it it's only to get in shape it
was very silly but it was a lot of fun
Michael Dukakis joke no you know Michael
Dukakis from 1988 door/window pants yes
I glasses these are nouns I know pop
announced all right I'm out okay I can't
he and rages me here edges here but
thank you for visiting us so much okay
thank you Bonin all right thank you so
much for stopping by
goodbye everybody let's try and solve it
tonight down please guys which way
through this scariest way that we are
not reassured to go there's an just an
open pit right here and a 400 foot
traffic and I'm not kidding you this
would be such an easy way we're trying
to lose one host by the end of the week
goodbye
we built that in
alright Conan O'Brien we're about to
check in with these guys but before we
get to that I just want to give a quick
shout out to our friends at DirecTV now
for making this whole thing possible and
bringing you insider access to your
favorite Konak on things tired of being
trapped in smothering year-long
contracts and the cable guys stomping
into your house while you install some
bulky Hardware just so you can watch
your favorite show well DirecTV now is
dish free with no annual contract or no
bulky hardware DirecTV now lets you
watch must have live TV shows networks
and more from anywhere have 10 or 11
hours to kill while you wait in line no
problem with DIRECTV now you can stream
your favorite shows right from where you
are wherever you are and that weight
will go by in no time no matter what you
like DirecTV now has more for your live
at Kona con face it speaking Konak on
things I want to get to what you guys
were up to today of course we have a
comment section going live right now so
leave us your comments I'll be getting
to those a little bit later in the show
but marina I understand that you were
down checking out some cosplay action
yes I was and I met a man and you know
like I said I'm looking for black people
this is just what I do I always look for
them see if they're here and I met black
man today okay black man we have a photo
of this I'm not familiar with this as an
official he's real superhero let's take
a look at that Wow look at that that's
what yeah awesome he's got his fro going
he's working out his black cape yeah
when he turns around it says black man
again it repeats Wow good branding you
could make anything down at comic-con
yeah What did he say are the superpowers
of black men titties oh he's fighting
stereotype oh so that's important he
wasn't like you know he wasn't like hey
if you had to create an original
superhero but would it be black girl
black girl it's not that original but I
think it would go with black man and
that's cool it'd be way more well
received and if I dressed up as fat well
yes you'd have some issues yeah
absolutely
we have to march against you yes and
superpowers a black woman does she need
it no not really I mean it's it's
already in me I mean look at this don't
come at me body by this hotel gym below
us superhero it's gotta be completely
original okay something that won't upset
our sponsors I I would definitely be the
Incredible Shrinking self esteem you
just when you think I can't be sadder
there I go get myself in the mirror Wow
just kidding I'm just like bum the
villains out too big I don't even wanted
nobody anymore let's just call it I
don't want I just got it I gotta go home
I gotta call my mom that sort of thing I
tell him my whole plan I like James Bond
thought I was gonna kill him in the
whole plan but he would just like say oh
I don't know I'm not I'll do it for you
yeah okay what a dark note flula want to
bring us up with my hero
yes which a hero which your original
hero a hero would be a robber to the
hydration cube he would be a man who was
actually made of electrolyte filled
water and he just slides down the street
and people may lick him as they get
thirsty okay this is a sanitary thing
he's ridin down the street as long as
you don't lick the bottom just go on the
sides
he's replenishing others everyone knows
who are thirsty give me your give me
your first steel white but why do you
have to be a cube do you turn into the
cube are you always if you are if you
are a sphere you will roll it too fast
and people will become rolled over do
you have to be are you a cube the whole
time or is your power that you turn into
a queue a cube would wet man it's the
most slow I know I you're misunderstood
I'm missing it do you just art do you
get up in the morning and are a cube and
then put on a mask and then go out as
cube i or do you wake up as you and then
transform into a cube this is a very
reasonable question cannot answer for
Robert I just know that Robert he's a
Cuban I love him because he's
he's a hydrating everyone chill with
hydration Rena you were also giving away
tickets oh yes I was yes I was another
reason to follow at Kona con is we're
doing giveaways all week so it's like
everything between challenges to like
meet us in this secret location that's
all going to the Instagram at Kona con
so you're out today you gave away
everyone's giving away two tickets this
week right yes so you you were you
caught up with some fans giveaways where
were you at I was at a place where you
dock boats which was a hint for where I
was act okay worked out let's take a
look at marina giving away some tickets
marina here I've got two tickets for
Conan live for tonight's show but here's
the thing you have to meet me it's that
my name's sake
have fun at Conan tonight oh and that's
the fan that got that ticket down where
sailors relieve themselves well it's my
name
marina that's what my mother gave me I
did you know you could take it for what
you want but that's the meaning of Who I
am I like it back boats oh I have so
many follow-ups but no no don't do it
Joe I'm not try a clean one no day one
John have it in me I won't
I won't but they all got it there's
several people who came sweating running
to a place where you dock boats it was
wonderfully dock boats marina you really
did some heavy lifting on the location
there from marina to marina
let's grab that video oh it's beautiful
it's the kind of that's gonna in-depth
work that you can expect here so that
was Jonas marina for your kona khan
ticket thing Joel yeah your thing you
were down and you actually stopped by a
house yeah yeah yeah movie exhibit mmm
yeah there's a lot of cool installations
that go on at comic-con and I just
happen to stumble on what I think is one
of the coolest installations here at
Comic Con this week okay and I think we
can actually take a look at that
so let's take a look at Joel's got more
for your movie thing let's take a look
at that so many cool installations here
at Comic Con this is a house they are
building an exact replica from the
beguiles you can go in there all this
week and get your own leg cut off just
like Colin Firth that is so cool
very immersive a very immersive and of
course that is actually just a house
that we passed it's just not a
regulation I should warn everyone for
the rest of this process that a lot of
my comedy is just lies it's very like aa
MIDI like that was just a house and yes
I know it's Colin Farrell not Colin
Firth their comments lighting up great I
know
correct Polly Farrell heads out there
really creepy meaning dude there is some
truth to it what do you mean if you
break in that house you probably will
get your legs right
is that was like surprisingly close to
the Convention Center it was last
holdout like rent control it's the old
couple with gorgeous house I wish that
comic-con would feature more Sophia
Coppola style installations give me a
Virgin Suicides installation where you
get to go and relive a tragedy in a
house something a little bit more subtle
than the Jack Ryan experience the fun
part where they were laying on the field
I do only watch you watch the first 30
minutes of Virgin Suicides merely lutely
good feel-good movie about our sisters
just having a good time in the 70s under
the bleachers what happens you don't
want to know okay yeah let's unpack the
entire movie Virgin Suicides shot by
shot in real time all the scenes for
Flula it's it's gonna be you know killer
to the same movie Instagram stories yeah
you were you were all over today and
yeah all your stuff is lies truth and
comedy they say but not how do you mean
no no unless he broke in the house I did
not
I didn't yeah and Conan called you out
for peeking into rehearsing did ya
startled by your by your appearance I
think we have video of you sure he
didn't
breaking into rehearsal so more for your
Konak on rehearsal thing
check out Joel at rehearsal
[Music]
did you walk in him changing no you
can't really see in the video but I he
is playing guitar
this is spoiler alert planning on
watching the show but he was playing
guitar and I was very shocked I always
forget how multi-talented are edible
bosses I don't know if he's playing on
the on the show tonight but he does for
all the rehearsals he he plays guitar oh
wow
because it keeps his brain active and it
also fills in the like awkward silence
oh sorry yeah yeah about that later I
did an interview with him but if you're
following at Kona con you can see that
but yeah he's saying like cuz he has to
like rehearse the jokes or like at least
run through them to see like which ones
they should cut and if he's just playing
then you can't hear like a ha ha from
the back like our lovely studio audience
here I love that I'm keeping your brain
active right yes very
yes gingko biloba and I also do morning
when I wake up in the morning I do some
push up immediate and then five sit-ups
immediate and then I scream and you
scream yes
okay what's the scream for it makes you
you are scaring yourself and you're like
oh I am a scary person and then you get
excited and then everything is normal in
the day you don't no one does this I
have not tried this I kind of want to
try get Slee tomorrow let's all scream
7:30 a.m. set the entire ships are you
doing
just 5 just 5 got a host the same time 3
didn't work no setup you didn't know no
skin no snow say that's why it didn't
work there are people screaming wing
there it is
of energy that does work to try that
terrifying German exercise at home
you're welcome viewers it very sorry to
the hotel surrounding us that her that
have all come to their windows we won't
do that again
don't worry that helicopter has been
circling yeah you're sure I think
they're trying to land yeah I think this
is the helicopter pad taken over yeah
the helicopter pad needs to do an
emergency landing right now perfect okay
incomes yes you were out there and
there's a donut shop that's creating
Kona con Donuts I think we have a photo
of you with the owner yes donut shop
show enough I got props from the kids in
the hill and my mom and my pops I have
no idea what you said but I know that it
was all one word with zero spaces house
of pain okay 91 nobody I can't tell if I
can't understand you or heatstroke is
legitimately setting and that's that's
the pole on Instagram post there didn't
have people answer mom-and-pop shop okay
so yeah Santiago
runs a donut shop let's take a look at
that photo of you with lovely Oh
Santiago yes that's with Conan doughnuts
yeah red one that he's holding looks you
almost poison it's very aggressively the
left one is what you call like oh heck
boy yeah hell boy
oh that's hell heck boy if we don't have
the rights to hell boy so we're gonna
say heck boy boy heck adolescent heck
out of but that's a very aggressive
donut like always in someone in a
cartoon yes doughnuts doughnuts and and
then you guys should got to give away
that donut to a person yeah person equal
height of equal height so Lula's got
more of your cone ik on thing let's roll
that so Brian
yes okay sorry yeah mrs. O'Brien I found
some donuts that look like you in a
dominant way and so they're from the
donut bar would you like to eat you know
it's would you like me to eat now would
you like me to eat would you say it
again are you okay yeah I have not even
in so far today alright so how these are
beautiful maybe you could have one and
keep it in Europe what is this called
it's a fanny pack I believe call it in
in Germany the funny part what you call
it in Ireland a mistake a mistake I feel
less good about me working out
push-ups yes what do you do what is the
secret my secret is I just stay as a
mogul as possible I drink a lot of heavy
cream heavy cream
[Laughter]
thank you
wow that's Flula given a doughnut to
Conan yes I did not realize it was Conan
he did oh you had no idea you thought
that was a stagehand I thought walking
around in the in Conan face yes
okay is huge here dad have been anybody
it really could have been someone Tilda
Swinton cosplay anybody yes
Tilda Swinton Tilda Swinton do you know
that name
no it sounds like a keyboard stroke of
America's premier Asian actresses do it
all how much of those doughnuts have you
had how much of that now had 3.5 of the
Conan face ones and then two of the
coolers cruller
it's like looks like someone has like
whipped a towel like this and before
they smack a bootie yeah
say it again like you whip a towel now
cooler say it again
hula say it again hula say it again hula
say it again hula say it again hula
water say it again cool what cooler
nasty cooler cooler you're suddenly
delirious like that yeah no you haven't
stop moving like your legs are planted
on the ground but I see your individual
muscles are gyrating my smaller tiny toe
is moving at all the times at all times
yeah yeah you're pretty hopped up I am
okay thanks what's a traditional German
sweet treat bow and flush Turk which
would be farmers breakfast which is a
fried potatoes eggs and a little bit of
chive that's a traditional German sweet
treat yes
your country is and night drives are in
a sweet treat green onions
have you visited my my half my family is
from there I'm you are coming home with
me and I'm gonna cook you some sassy
desserts
that was a lie it's just you're like
comedy that you did cuz I'm not gonna
get into the aisle to show me your DNA
I'll show you do you guys wanna see Joel
getting boosters birth certificate just
what do you think we both have in common
all families from Germany I love to tell
you this what really
this is amazing you're rated hot rina
rina rina that's great okay so you guys
are gonna be out at comic-con tomorrow
yes anything you're specifically excited
to see Wow I'm like legit I'm legit
excited to meet some dogs and cosplay
yeah
real dogs the people of San Diego have
been very stingy about letting me take
pictures with their dogs yes I feel very
entitled to your dogs but I'm excited to
meet some dogs and costumes that's what
I okay because they're they're very
spotty they immediately want to get out
of it projected their own interests onto
a living creature that has no control
over their own great and Loula in
addition to catching butterflies which
you're about to do yes what are you
excited to see tomorrow
I like to watch I want to see how many
spider-man's I may find how many
spider-man yes I want to accomplish
spider-man's
where it's like varying weight sizes yes
Heights
yes weight and height and trust agility
hobbies hobbies really get to know him
have a real sit-down it is intense
spider-man and some spider-man you okay
yeah we'll get you a costume at that
marina things I want to do tomorrow yeah
I want to speak to a lot of women who
are powerful and strong and in short
possibly this time and then I also want
to see cats because I'm more of a cat
person so I want to I want to be at the
the cat store I think that's what it's
called a cat store cat store absolutely
it's like there's like a down here
there's like a cat experience you can
walk in or something you can go in you
can hang out with the cats and you can
approach them carefully okay okay great
Chloe some fan questions coming in are
you checking email yeah the only way
because I could get the tablet to work
there's gonna be on my phone yeah
absolutely I love that project you're
working on Joe absolutely Conan live
needs to happen more often please that's
all from YouTube okay not really a
question but we appreciate the positive
feedback about yourself thank you yes
Joe I'd like to take a picture I would
like you to take a picture with my dog
please I just really wanted to get more
dogs
Conan's Rd Sundberg greetings from
Argentina Austin from yeah hola I'm not
gonna cracked you this is comes this is
for marina Liz on YouTube wants to know
how was your first day in San Diego wow
they must know I'm not from here so my
first in San Diego was culture shock
because people were so kind
well bumped into someone and I said I'm
sorry and they were like no I bumped
into you I shouldn't know they said I
shouldn't have been here just chill
beach people with sunburned eyes walking
around just hey whatever you want you
could park there it's great so kind so
kind and probably cuz you have free
stuff too to give away
oh that's goes a long way you got a
conan badge people probably stop you on
the streets right I have seen people
smiling at me way before they should
I've done anything to create happy yeah
I smile before I even knew anything
about you you're good
look at that was the ticket giveaway
crazy
Joel you also give away tech yeah we
give away tickets I have to say I felt
really shady because right before we
posted the video revealing my location
we saw three people that said oh are you
about to give away tickets and I was
like yeah yeah check keep checking and
then as they walked feet away we posted
it and then another woman came and they
I made some enemies they were very upset
with me for not giving them the heads up
that they should have just hung around
me for a couple more minutes now I know
why your Instagram is at I hate Rome
okay so make sure you follow that I hate
Joel so make sure you're watching I the
Conan show tonight this is the pre-show
he we're about to head down there and
watch the actual show he's got the
entire cast of Breaking Bad
yes that's correct that means it's a
reunion of the entire cast
Bryan Cranston Aaron Paul and a gun Dean
Norris Betsy Brandt
RJ Mitte Bob Odenkirk Vince Gillian and
Giancarlo Esposito and the total that
they exploded you Roberto
toda are gonna piece it together
and real yeah you gotta tune in that you
are so far I know that it is the statute
of limitations on the streets give him
spoiler Dumbledore dies he'll be out
there on the streets on these sweaty
streets of San Diego at comic-con but in
posting stuff to at comic-con so make
sure you're following at Konak on their
individual accounts and yeah we'll see
you guys out there all week a huge thank
you for stopping by the show he's
actually gonna stop by tomorrow which is
an after show so make sure you're tuning
in for that that's after the show will
have mower for of your Conner
Conan Con thing Oh week right here from
the rooftop of the Spreckels theater
we'll see you tomorrow for our live at
Kona con post show i'm moses storm thank
you guys so much and thank you to our
lovely correspondent great work Moses
stood day I would say good night but
it's only getting brighter
[Music]